[Musique]
la guerre est pleine d'incertitudes
nous attaquerons lorsque la lune sera au
plus haut les elfes de la pleine lune
sont des soldats d'élite redoutable qui
n'a qu'à aller voir les elfes pour faire
la paix ce n'est pas aussi simple
nous parlons de siècle et deux siècles
d'histoire
les humains ont anéanti le roi des
dragons puis ils ont décrit son sol et
celui du printemps avant la justice sera
tout prix rendue il faut vraiment que tu
vois ça cette découverte change
considérablement les choses il pourra
peut-être arrêter la guerre l'avenir est
entre nos mains
c'est à nous de ramener cette fac sadia
rassemble des hommes est troublée
et bien moi je vais trouver un moyen de
les vaincre après tout on est
invulnérable que si l'on a été
vulnérable non ce n'est pas tout à fait
vrai
[Musique]
a réussi à s'en sortir tous les quatre
et ça y est on sera
[Musique]